where are left motorcar diner in Central
City no I meant what here I went back in
time and created a whole new existence
so there's a timeline out
I'm not rich what's a virtual universe a
flash season premiere Tuesday October
4th on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie so stealth
flash trailer dropped teasing some
sabotage speed cold
it looks very familiar if you've read
the comics or if you're a big fan of
Star Trek Deep Space 9 so I'm just gonna
do a breakdown and I'll explain what's
going on okay big stuff first so Barry
looks like he's taking one of the other
entrances into STAR Labs like he's
sneaking in but everything looks
different decrepid you see him walk into
the diner with his dad he thinks that
he's in the wrong time he starts to
explain like the other voice over where
he's explaining how he created
flashpoint is all taken from a separate
conversation that he's having in STAR
Labs here as he's trying to explain you
guys like drawing it on the board for
the rest of the people you see Wally's
standing back here so like all trailers
they're mixing and matching scenes from
different parts of the episode you see
scenes from season two of stuff that
happened during that other timeline and
then the big joke at the end is Cisco
going you mean there's another version
of me without any money that's a glitch
in the universe just like we the
audience are like oh my god oh no you
know everything's changed but from his
perspective you know rich Cisco
is like this is the correct timeline the
Cisco from your timeline sounds
ridiculous the other big thing is the
presence of the drums very tribal kind
of a hat tip to sabotage speed cult
which is what I think this is this scene
here now Greg Berlanti actually said
something really important earlier today
where people were reporting that the
actor from Vampire Diaries that everyone
thought is playing that black flash that
we've all seen pictures of is savat are
but he's like no no no everyone we
haven't cast's avatar yet so that raises
a whole bunch of red flags but i think
thats avatar is this person here that's
all hunched over in the robes that you
can't see they're doing kind of a zoom
type thing where they don't reveal his
face for a while so maybe they're still
looking for the actor maybe they don't
reveal him right away but he's only one
of the big bads
the other big bad this season is dr.
alchemy but I feel like this is sabotage
speed cult because it looks like he
asked these other worshippers there with
them so if you don't know what's avatar
speed cult is it's something from the
Wally West air in the comics some from
way way back but he basically you know
the TV show version worships the Speed
Force as this kind of divine Deep Space
9 Cisco wormhole aliens type thing one
of the most important things they did
last season was actually
see the speedforce wormhole aliens
anybody who's watched Star Trek Deep
Space nine has a pretty good idea
they're kind of like these metaphysical
transdimensional beings that exist way
beyond our comprehension it seems like
what the TV show is gonna do is it'll
use Savatage speed cult and it'll say
that he worships those beings and that's
just something that will probably get
teases for in the first couple of
episodes however much they end up
showing him but like all cults usually
they only benefit the cult leader namely
Savitt are so you have like this leader
preaching this way of life and everyone
buys into it but really the cult leader
uses the cult to make himself more
powerful in some way in this context
obviously it's the speedforce they're
worshipping so Sabbat are wants to be
one with the Speed Force that was one of
the big arcs of his in the comics where
during rebirth of you guys haven't read
Jeff John's rebirth he's like I'm gonna
give you what you wanted sabot R I'm
gonna make you one with the Speed Force
but the big twist is is that you can't
force the Speed Force into your body I
know that sentence seems kind of weird
but it's just the way that Barry takes
savage hard down in the comics like you
want the power you want to be one with
it and he just like turns the juice on
opens the firehose of the Speed Force
and he just vaporizes into nothingness
the same way Barry did when he got
trapped in the Speed Force so what I'm
expecting is is the tv-show will change
the comic book storyline a little bit
but you'll see some very familiar comic
books avatar things so you don't have to
read the flash comics to understand
what's going on with Savitt are because
the TV show always changes a few minor
things but it will help a little bit
like I said with respect to this avatar
speed cult stuff I'm getting a very Deep
Space nine vibe so if you really want to
go like an inception level deeper and
prepare for the flash watch Deep Space
nine and think about the way they wove
in the beador and religion to that like
how the entire Bajoran religion was
based around the wormhole aliens now
imagine it's the flash TV show and it's
the Speed Force wormhole aliens and in
place of Cisco you have Barry who is
kind of like half-man half-god but as
we're talking about the TV show think
about him more as a Speed God but like
on Deep Space nine there were evil Speed
Force wormhole aliens Sabbat are
actually
sounds kind of like a gold ducat figure
in the course of deep space night like
by the end of that series
he also ascended to godhood but he had
been possessed by an evil wormhole alien
so maybe we'll see evil speed force
wormhole aliens this season I have no
idea but just think sabot are gold ducat
Barry Benjamin Sisko I just I really
like that idea
especially if you're big Deep Space nine
fan this season is gonna be a lot of fun
the Greg Berlanti comment so this is
actually a big question mark if he's
saying that this is not Savitt are
because this is very definitely that
Vampire Diaries actor who's actually
like a relatively known quantity it's
not like he's a nobody so that would
imply that this black flash is a
completely different character so just
remains to be seen of how that works and
if he's gonna be in the first couple of
episodes he's got to be a relatively big
deal but maybe he'll be attached to
sabotage speed cult in some way so no
idea what his name's gonna be there are
a number of different comic book names
they could use for him if this is not
Sava tar but for now we'll just continue
to call him the new black flash but I do
like the idea that he's actually a
pretty big character from the comics
that we'll find out about really soon so
let me know in the comments what do you
most hype about just looking at this
footage I'm really interested to see
savatage speed cult and how that weaves
into the mythology of the season just
because it's recontextualizing the Speed
Force on the TV show is turning in it to
more of a religious thing which is very
Star Trek Deep Space Nine and that was
one of my favorite Star Trek TV shows
but part of the big arc of buried this
season not only is fixing flashpoint
like everybody's read the flashpoint
story or you've seen the cartoon movie
so you have an idea of how it plays out
but the big idea is is that Barry has
created this new family in STAR Labs in
the arc of this season will be him
getting to know that family so I was
originally gonna do a killer frost video
so I'll just push that by a couple more
days but there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card so I'll announce the winner when I
post my next DC video so get hype
they'll probably be like another big
trailer really soon - so why you guys
wait for my next video you can click
here to learn about the big Thor
Ragnarok Doctor Strange crossover that's
happening in the
you can click here for my breakdown to
the gardens of the galaxy 2 trailer
scene they just released some more
concept art thank you so much for
watching everybody it looks like five
I'll see you guys tonight